這個是我31歲零項目的眼中狀態
眼睛是亮亮的基本上沒有什麼穩怒
眼周也是感覺很緊制的
但其實我25歲左右的眼部狀態比現在是要差很多的
我常常說過很多辦法
但是真的如果眼部狀態你洗靠的其實是我
近在家著摸的眼部呼呼和護理流程
那眼周它是我們整張臉最保而且沒有皮色線的地方
這我們勇氣對於柔印線的地方
而且25歲以後的眼周變了
它不僅僅其實說長幾條穩怒那麼簡單
大部分都是穩怒鬆持內閣奧線全部都站
讓我們看起來非常非常的皮背巧脆
所以眼周的呼籲非常非常重要
那今天來分享一個新手也可以零食物的按摩手法
堅持下來乾穩納鬆持內閣這條問題都是可以肉眼的看到改善的
現在我喜歡鏈子
先同一個臉部精華讓臉不要太乾
再來準備一個臉部精華
像我們油皮旋臉部產品一定要精采
我之前真的是太了很多的坑
跟風擺了超多那種很厚重的眼妝
效果是有的
但是圖案之後我只能跟眼周真的都是油膩膩的
就溫度眼周長了好多脂肪力
要麼足夠輕爽
但是一點用都沒有
它就在我的眼周扯來扯去感覺這個溫度越來越深
我用的這品是這個
深哥藍的SOS眼睛化
它是那種能同時做到輕爽和高效的
用效全手
它們加倍後的時間是7般雅那邊的
是太大廠了一個廚
非常捨得用了
就不是圖個心理安櫃的那種唇暴時款
這一品直接三款其下
打乾溫細溫鬆紙下
垂溫高歐縣這三大八個一過端了
針對以原文
它是足足對了百分之時
雙下的任何肉肉太複配
就不管是一項就擠出來的這種洞太表情溫
還是說已經形成的靜胎乾溫細溫
它都可以搞定
一邊幫我們一致表情溫反覆加深
一邊幫我們從基底裡面處理
一形和三形交園
把已經長出來的乾溫細溫甜品
所以用酒真會感覺很明顯
就是眼周的這個溫度會淡超多
然後化妝都不怎麼談分了
最近讓我經驗的是他的提娜警制力
就很多人他只在眼周的眼文
但是其實忽略了
宋使下唇一才是我們顯老的重點
他用到了三太警數
可能可以慢慢地加溫溫眼周的支撐力
把那些宋化下唇的眼皮給
直接來不只吃說表面警鋒的用假象
而是幫我們把皮膚底成的解決
也夠變緊實了
像眼位之裡都感覺力度精緻了很多
皮拉感就是很持久
不會說你一體用去打個原性
他就像是那種除落式的
對我們日常最難搞的
內閣歐縣也是很有用的
一邊幫我們出關鍵交園
一邊幫我們所住
我們眼周的水分寒
讓我們的內閣碰起來
所以堅持優雅你會感覺
內閣的這個陰影感
會變態不少
就整個人看起來是那種很飽滿年輕的
那我們現在就開始按摩囉
先來圖
兩棟眼睛寬
充分子任我們的眼周的肌膚
和我們的手指
整個全部眼光這一圈
都要塗到
給大家看一下他的致體
它是最重
非常輕透的地種
精華而如夜的致體
就是一模就會跨開了
所以吸收速度非常快
完全不會年齡
不用擔心說會蜜蜘蛛
一樣或抽你什麼的
早上用之後
後面跌架採裝也是完全OK的
但保持都也是很勾的
所以用它來搭配我的這個按摩手法
也完全不會拉扯到我們的皮膚
我們現在做一個
大家都會的眼寶漸操的第四階
倫關眼光
可以放鬆我們眼周所有的地方
大膜只放在我們太陽碎地方
然後其他手指帶握起來
實質的這個直接
新關我們的上眼光
再從眼頭
關到下眼光
就這樣重複大家組
這一步的話主要設備的
促進我們的眼周的循環
讓我們的經過運行起來
做完了
先感覺整個眼周的放鬆
而且瞬間眼周的這種
泡河中種的那種服裝感沒有了
再用我們的中指和無名指
在我們的眼下定隔
然後把它提上去
要定隔三秒鐘
然後我們重複
大家到十足
有人留著讓它定隔上去
還是用我們的實質關鍵
來掛我們的
每一碼上面
這一部份的肌肉
放鬆這上面的肌肉
可以環節我們的沒新聞的
你可以讓我們的眼周提拉上去
這個也是重複搬到實質
從我們的沒新關到的太陽碎
再就是用三根手指
輕輕的按壓我們的眼光正下方
然後左右來回的鬆緊
你會感覺有一點酸酸脹脹
然後再用手指眼中的下眼光
來回的敲打到太陽碎
這一步可以環節眼部的壓力
大家就是做一分鐘左右就可以了
真的很舒服
最後就是我們把雙手脆熱
覆蓋著我們眼部
給眼部進行一個加熱放鬆
或者用這種打施的
就我們也讓精神上熱水
豬肉的眼中
熱膚對環節
我們眼周的皮膚
和眼圈的幫助非常非常大
那做完這組就感覺我們眼周是
特別特別的舒服的
熱熱短
然後眼睛也是感覺亮亮的
整個眼睛都是像上走的
這個眼睛畫很好心說
所以我們也不用洗掉
剛才我熱膚的時候
其實你帶走的一些了
那我們現在再圖
一起們同系列的這個SOS精華就可以了
它跟我們的眼睛
它的核心是一樣的
就是裡面有三重溫柔臺
對付像法令文
和臺偷文
還有我們的溫柔的景質效果都非常好
而且像它的膚感也是很清爽的
我們有動機
用讓完全沒有壓力
好啦今天的眼部
莫莫理就完成了
大家都可以吃試試